es oficial finlandia y suecia formarán
parte de la otan los 30 países miembros
de la organización trasatlántica ya
firmaron en bruselas bélgica los
protocolos para la adhesión de los dos
países
a néstor y este es un día histórico para
finlandia para suecia para la otan y
para la seguridad euroatlántica for your
land twitter security la firma se
produce luego de semanas de
negociaciones con turquía país que
quería hacer uso de su membresía para
vetar la entrada de finlandia y suecia
debido a su supuesto apoyo al pkk un
partido político del kurdistán turco
considerado como un grupo terrorista por
el gobierno del presidente recep tayeb
erdogán pero las partes ya llegaron a un
acuerdo en la última cumbre de la
alianza en la capital española madrid en
disco documental en este documento en
este memorando hemos abordado todas las
preocupaciones planteadas por turquía
incluidos los terroristas el pkk y todos
los pasos necesarios que se tomarán se
mencionan en el memorando
y realmente espero un proceso de
ratificación rápido y como saben hicimos
un memorando de entendimiento entre
finlandia suecia y turquía para abordar
la preocupación de turquía en lo que
respecta a la seguridad y el terrorismo
[Música]
helsinki y estocolmo ahora sólo deben
esperar la ratificación de la decisión
para su integración un proceso interno
el cual se encarga a cada país miembro y
que puede demorarse meses sin embargo
hasta que se esta ratificación suecia y
finlandia no podrán beneficiarse del
artículo 5 de la carta de la otan que
estipula que un ataque armado contra un
país miembro de la alianza será
considerado como un ataque contra todos
ellos